[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à cet entretien de
France 24 nous recevons aujourd'hui les
mystères spéciales pour l'Iran des
États-Unis Robert Malki est avec nous
depuis les départements des tawashington
merci d'être avec nous merci de nous
recevoir
une vague de manifestation sans
précédent depuis qu'une jeune femme de
22 ans Macha Amini est morte le 16
septembre
après avoir été arrêté par la police des
mœurs ce terrain parce qu'elle ne
portait pas bien son voile on voit
l'obligatoire
malgré la répression très brutale les
manifestations se poursuivent ce
mercredi en particulier 40 jours depuis
sa mort et à la fin de la période de
deuil en Iran vous avez récemment
déclaré que les manifestants réclamaient
du respect du régime du respect de leur
droit de l'homme de la part du régime
iranien mais apparemment il demande
davantage il scandait mort au dictateur
bénévole le changement de régime
comme vous l'avez dit cette journée est
très importante pour beaucoup d'Iraniens
iraniennes ça fait 40 jours
que ma salle mini est morte elle est
décédée pendant sa détention par la
police des mœurs il y a dans toutes les
rangs des manifestations on voit des
manifestants créatifs courageux qui font
face à une répression extrêmement
brutale
ils sont personnellement menacés nous
regardons avec attention ce qui se
déroule en Iran nous parlons plus tard
j'imagine des mesures que nous prenons
pour sanctionner ceux qui sont
responsables de la répression vous avez
fait référence à quelque chose que j'ai
dit j'ai corrigé ce que j'avais dit un
jour après ça n'est pas mon rôle ça
n'est pas le rôle du gouvernement
américain que de caractériser les
attentes du peuple iranien ou des
manifestants c'est leur rôle ce que nous
pouvons faire c'est les soutenir
soutenir leur lutte pour l'endroit
fondamentaux et sanctionné et mettre en
lumière ceux qui utilisent une violence
extrême pour les réprimer celle que nous
faisons
nous assurons également que les Iraniens
aient accès Internet pour communiquer
entre eux et avec le monde d'accord vous
avez parlé de sanction le gouvernement
by down a imposé les sanctions tout
comme l'Union européenne est-ce que
c'est suffisant ou est-ce que l'on
prépare davantage de sanctions parce que
comme on l'a dit les manifestations se
poursuivent la répression également
nous sommes en train d'annoncer un
nouveau train de sanction train de
sanction
qui touchera les leaders de la
République islamique d'Iran qui sont
impliqués dans la répression les
responsables de l'administration
pénitentiaire en particulier ceux de la
célèbre représentés
de Orange mais également les
responsables de terrain qui sont
impliqués dans la répression violente de
manifestations pacifiques il pensait
pouvoir se cacher être anonyme mais nous
allons les désigner les cibler et nous
allons également toucher ceux qui
veulent censurer et réprimer les
manifestants pacifiques en Iran donc
davantage de sanctions en se quarantième
jour depuis la mort de Massa à Nimy
d'accord est-ce que c'est sanctions
pourraient porter sur le président
raciste par exemple c'est ce que demande
certains responsables américains
il est déjà sous sanction je pense que
vous le savez et ça fait un moment dont
déjà d'accord
créer un nouveau mécanisme des Nations
Unies pour repérer les excès qu'on a vu
par exemple en Syrie au miel est-ce que
les États-Unis seraient en faveur de la
création d'un tel mécanisme
concernant ce qui se passe actuellement
en Iran
ok
mécanisme international nous
réfléchissons avec nos partenaires du
monde entier les Européens bien sûr mais
également les pays du Sud global
beaucoup sont scandalisés parce qu'il
voit en Iran avec cette répression
brutale contre des manifestations
pacifiques nous réfléchissons à ce que
nous pouvons faire pour que ceux qui
sont responsables de cette répression
brutale rendez compte
il y a aussi de toute évidence un train
de sanction contre le rôle de l'Iran
supposé en Ukraine on a beaucoup parlé
de drones iraniens utilisés par la
Russie et même des personnels militaires
iraniens sur place en Crimée pour aider
Moscou à effectuer ses attaques par
drone en Ukraine
avez-vous vu d'autres indications d'une
participation iranienne avec la Russie
des drones des dizaines peut-être des
centaines à la Russie nous savons que
l'Iran forme les opérateurs russes et
nous savons que ces drones sont utilisés
par la Russie pour frapper des civils et
des infrastructures civiles enfin
nous savons que les Iraniens sont si
gênés qu'il continue à mentir et ce
malgré les preuves qui s'accumulent de
ton transfert de drone la communauté
internationale
dans son ensemble
regarde cette situation car c'est
extraordinaire que de voir l'Iran
s'impliquer dans cette guerre
d'agression injustifiée de la Russie
contre l'Ukraine les Ukrainiens
souffrent énormément et nous allons
sanctionner tous ceux qui sont appliqués
dans ces transferts nous allons
présenter toutes les preuves que nous
avons mais maintenant la situation est
très claire les experts ont témoigné
devant l'ONU tout le monde voit bien ce
qui se passe et au premier chef les
Ukrainiens qui en souffrent nous
travaillons pour que les rangs vous avez
mené les négociations indirectes avec
l'Iran concernant son programme
nucléaire étant donné ce qui se passe
actuellement est-ce que c'est
négociation sont terminées ou simplement
suspendus
très clairement on se concentre sur les
zones où il y a des avancées il n'y a
pas eu d'avancées sur l'accord sur le
nucléaire depuis novembre l'Iran a une
position qui est incompatible avec une
reprise du processus nous nous
concentrons sur les avancées il y a des
avancées dans les rues iraniennes il y a
ces manifestations dans les rues
pacifiquement chaque jour le monde
regarde et le monde regarde également
l'autre enjeu que vous avez mentionné
c'est-à-dire celui des transferts de
drones de l'Iran à la Russie utilisé
pour tuer des Ukrainiens c'est ce sur
quoi nous travaillons car c'est ce qui
se passe en ce moment
donc il n'y a plus de négociation sur la
question nucléaire avec l'Iran
actuellement c'est cela
cela fait un moment qu'il n'y a plus de
négociation effectivement
le 23 octobre le ministre d'affaires
étrangères a déclaré que l'Iran avait
reçu un message des États-Unis trois
jours auparavant le 20 octobre disons
que les Américains sont pressés de
parvenir à un accord avec l'Iran est-ce
que vous avez transmis ce message à
Téhéran
bien sûr que non
ce sont les mêmes que ceux qui disent
que Massa Amini est morte de cause
naturelle les mêmes
qui nient le transfert de drone de
l'Iran à la Russie donc je pense qu'il
faut prendre ces allégations pour ce
qu'elles sont si on envoyait un message
à l'Iran ce sera un message simple
arrêtez de massacrer vos citoyens
arrêter de transférer des drones à la
Russie pour massacrer des Ukrainiens ça
serait ça notre message et tout le reste
est aussi vrai ou faux que le reste
d'accord ce qui semble être vrai et vous
y avez fait allusion c'est que vous
étiez tout près dans l'accord en août
selon les sources iraniennes européennes
et américaines et ça c'était avant la
répression qui aboutit à la discussion
qu'on a évoqué que s'est-il passé
il s'est passé quelque chose de très
simple
ce n'est pas que nous qui disons mais
les Européens l'Union européenne le dit
avec son médiateur l'Iran a subitement
changé de cap l'Iran a subitement
présenté des demandes qui sont
incompatibles avec une reprise des
négociations sur le nucléaire et
aujourd'hui nous travaillons sur ce qui
compte pour le peuple iranien c'est à
dire les manifestations contre le régime
et nous travaillons une fois de plus sur
l'enjeu des transferts de drones à la
Russie d'accord
vous avez évoqué l'Internet les
États-Unis ont également assoupli leurs
sanctions sur les sociétés
technologiques qui aident les Iraniens à
échapper à l'emprise du gouvernement sur
l'Internet bien sûr il y a l'exemple de
l'Ukraine ou Elon Musk a fourni
déterminant Starling
est-ce que c'est ce que les États-Unis
envisagent pour aider les Iraniens à
communiquer entre eux et avec le reste
du monde est-ce que c'est
essentiellement ce que vous avez prévu
je ne vais pas rentrer dans les détails
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
nous sommes en contact avec les sociétés
technologiques de manière très directe
nous avons annoncé quels auraient
l'autorisation de fournir de
l'assistance aux Iraniens qui veulent
être aidés qui veulent contourner la
censure que le gouvernement impose nous
sommes en contact avec ces entreprises
pour leur dire que nous n'allons pas
sanctionner les activités qui étaient
sanctionnées auparavant nous
assouplissons les sanctions afin que les
Iraniens et la capacité de communiquer
entre eux alors que le gouvernement
tente de les en empêcher la capacité de
communiquer avec le monde et d'entendre
du monde extérieur ce que le monde a à
dire au moment où il se battent pour le
droit fondamentaux
dernière question celle des citoyens
américains et d'autres pays occidentaux
qui sont d'être mis en Iran l'Iran à
libérer un Américain Bakker la magie
tout récemment est-ce qu'il y a encore
des discussions pour libérer d'autres
détenus yamak d'autres citoyens nous
savons que la France a des deux citoyens
considérés comme des otages est-ce que
l'Iran continue de vous parler
indirectement de les libérer que moyen
de négociation pour réduire la pression
qui pèse sur eux
tout d'abord
c'est absolument scandaleux que l'Iran
utilise des personnes innocentes comme
des pions vous avez évoqué les Français
mais il est également d'autres
nationalités européennes et trois
citoyens américains vous avez parlé de
siamac mais également Aimad et Morad
tous les trois aucun d'entre eux
n'aurait dû être emprisonné ils doivent
être relâchés dès que possible être
réuni avec leur famille nous continuons
à faire tout ce que nous pouvons pour
leur permettre de rentrer le plus tôt
possible nous cherchons les voies et
moyens d'accélérer le processus c'est
notre priorité absolue que de les faire
rentrer chez eux et de les réunir avec
leurs proches
merci nous n'avons plus de temps merci
infiniment de vous être prêté à cet
entretien de France 24 merci de l'avoir
regardé et rester avec nous
[Musique]